hi there today we're looking at
synthetic petri dish a novel surrogate
model for rapid architecture search by a
doTERRA Wall Joe Lehmann Philippe
Petrovsky such Jeff Clun and Kenneth Oh
Stanley this paper on a high level
it basically says if you want to do
neural architecture search if you for
example search for a better
non-linearity you should be able to
extract that non-linearity instantiate
it in a very small network and then
evaluate that very small network in
order to predict the performance of a
large network and therefore you can find
a better non-linearity in much less time
now the exact procedure how you do this
in the small network is the topic of
this paper as always if you like content
like this I encourage you to subscribe
if you are not already and to share out
the video so other people can experience
the joy in themselves
alright let's dive in so they say in the
abstract neural architecture search
explores a large space of architectural
motives which which basically so it
basically means you want to find a
neural architecture let's say you have a
multi-layer perceptron right here a
couple of layers okay and they're all
connected by you know feed-forward
weights whatnot and each of these
weights basically is a multiplication so
each one of these is a multiplication of
X by your weight W and then there is a
non-linearity so the non-linearity could
be a sigmoid so the sigmoid would be
something like 1 over 1 plus e to the
negative X now there's a bit of an
extension in a sigmoid where you can do
a sigmoid that has like a a temperature
parameter attached or a slope parameter
where you go see X so in one case you
can set C such that the sigmoid has a
shape like this and in then if you put C
to a different value you can make this
slope you can make it like a shape well
terrible like this you know what I mean
okay so this this see right here can
potentially change the behavior of your
network and you want to find a good
parameter C and this is a hyper
parameter now there are many hyper
parameters like this for example how
many units you have in a particular
layer in a CNN it could be your filter
size in a transformer could be the
number of heads and so on it could
actually be not only the slope of the
non-linearity but the actual
non-linearity itself or famously in
recurrent neural networks you have these
recurrent cells and they're like okay we
have an input signal and a carry signal
and then the in the input here is like
dot multiplied here and then there is
like a gate with a non-linearity and
then it's kind of like multiplied by the
carry but then there is also a like a
forget gate and what know there's a
minus right here it's very complicated
and so people do architecture search
over these kind of problems to find
better architectures for particular
problems now the problem is of course
that how do you know if if a given
architecture is good what you have to do
is you'll have to go take that cell that
you have dreamed up you think well I
think that's a good cell and you have to
train it on the full training data set
this is a data set a database right this
is a full training data set then you
need to evaluate it on your validation
data set and then you have like a number
you have like okay this is 8 good and
then you go back and you say ok what if
I change this cell here what if I change
it to a plus instead of a minus and you
do the entire thing again
train it for I don't know how much
validate it and then this is like a 9
and you can say oh cool that's a 9 so
this is the very basic architecture
search and there has been a lot of
development in this space so like
evolutionary search and so on but they
most of the time they require pretty
much evaluating the entire thing on the
full data so you get a good you get a
good estimate of
what your final performance back here is
going to be now people have come up with
methods to counter that and they say
well if we can sort of encode the cell
structure let's go with the let's go
with the or NN cell if we could encode
the cell structure in in a sort of a
continuous way so you know we can encode
text in a continuous way let we could
also encode a cell structure because the
cell structure I can write it down as an
equation I can say like okay it's the
forget gate of the carry times the
sigmoid output of X plus V so this is
the plus here and plus the sigmoid
output of X multiplied by the input
let's call that I something like this
right
this is text I can like write it down
and then I can encode that into a vector
much I can for example build another RN
n ironically or or something to to
encode that or I can represent it as a
computation graph like it is here and
use a graph neural network to encode
that into a single vector and then I
have sort of an embedding space where
each cell that I could build is a point
in that embedding space and then I can
evaluate a couple of them I can for
example say okay this one here this one
here this one here this one here I'm
going to train them these cells I'm
going to do the full training eval and
so on get their scores and then I can
learn basically in this latent space I
can learn a predictor I can say okay
here I get I got an eight I got a nine I
got a two and I got a four so it appears
to be that in this direction that the
good cells are in this direction and
then I can do it again I can sample or I
can do gradient descent in this space
since this is now a continuous space and
do gradient descent on the model that
gives me the space right so this this
method basically tries to take in the
building plan of a cell and learn to
pray
the performance just by looking at it if
if you're thinking of the Turing machine
right now then you like I immediately
thought of like this this halting
problem because it appears to be exactly
what it is so you're trying to build a
machine that takes the building plan of
another machine and tries to predict its
performance now in in a general sense we
can already state that this problem is
sort of the difficulty of this problem
is equivalent to the difficulty of the
original problem so I'm not sure but it
appears to you know it appears to work
if you throw lots of compute at it but
of course that's a problem you need lots
of compute right so either your your
option one is to run all of these things
and kind of iterate them in a neural
sorry in an evolutionary way or your
second option is to take the building
plan and predict the performance from
that both are not satisfactory and both
we use lots of compute now neural petri
dish is a or synthetic petri dish is a
way to combine the two together it says
can we take the building plan' here but
actually run on the data on data to
predict the performance so what they're
saying is basically if I have this cell
right here and usually this cell you
know it deals with vectors of let's say
size 512 and so on it will say it since
this is let me draw it again up here so
here you have the cell and here you have
somehow the connections in there when
you carry and the input and the input
here okay and this is the output or the
carry
I have 512 embedding like size of this
so this is a giant cell there's 512 the
vector is 512 dimensions going in
basically can't I take the exact same
thing but and keep the connection
pattern so I would keep the entire
pattern of connection right here but I
only do it for one or two so this is 512
and this is just to write it's just the
D I just reduce the dimensionality but I
sort of keep the connection pattern
alive if I only do that I have like a
very small network right now and the
same goes for if this is so a lot of
times these are n ends they have
multiple layers of these things so
they'd have another exactly equal box up
here and then another up here I can just
reduce this to one layer and out of the
regularity of these neural network
things it is known that or one can make
the assumption that the performance on
this thing will sort of kind of be
correlated to the performance of the
entire thing and that's one of the
things that this petri dish paper does
so we try to take out what we are trying
to search over namely the connection
pattern we keep that as it is up here
but we reduce everything else we reduce
the dimensionality we reduce the number
of layers and so on now they don't
actually reduce the number of layers
here but you can reduce the number of
units and so on okay so this in essence
this works whenever you can do that
whenever you can keep the structure
you're searching over but can reduce the
rest so that's one precondition doesn't
work for everything the second part here
is that you don't want to use this
particular training data and then this
particular validation data because first
of all it's a lot of training data and
second of all it won't give you that
good of a prediction in stead of what
you're trying to do and this is the
second part of the idea of petri dish is
you're trying to abstract the training
data to get you a very small data set
such that and the validation data were
as well searched that if you train on
this data and evaluate on
data the performance that you get will
be very predictive of the performance
had you trained the big model on the big
data set okay
in fact in this petri dish paper these
little data sets they have nothing to do
with the with the original train and
validation data and that's I think
that's one of the cool things here these
things this training data and this
validation data they are optimized as
well by the procedure they're optimized
special data points that are trained
these are trained parameters such that
if you train on the training and the
small training date and evaluate on the
small eval data the you will be able to
predict this performance back here with
high accuracy okay and this I think is
where previous approaches have or might
have failed because it's you know the
idea of scaling down your network in
order to do the architecture search is
probably as it has appeared to many
people before that's not you know that's
not really genius idea but probably they
have all found that now we can't really
do it it doesn't really give us accurate
enough numbers but in this case the
addition of adding these synthetic data
sets that are much smaller but can still
if you train and evaluate on them can
still predict with high accuracy the
full score of the full model that I
think makes this idea work alright so I
guess we're already through the idea and
problem setting and everything without
actually reading the paper
so they give this example right here at
the beginning that if you have a a
two-layer 100 wide so 100 dimensional
emne snakes it's two layers it's I think
it's an ml piece to layer MLP with a
non-linearity that is this this sigmoid
right here this okay now you can see it
has this temperature parameter here it
has this slope parameter
and you you want to do neural
architecture search to find the best
slope parameter and usually you would
just do a grid search but this isn't
this is an example because this can be
of course much higher dimensional things
and then you don't want to do grid
search anymore okay so what do we do if
you look at how the 100 white emne snake
so we can draw it right here so this is
a 100 dimensional emne snake work so
this is 100 and each cell each
connection here first has a weight and
then has the sigmoid non-linearity and
the sigmoid non-linearity is
parametrized by the parameter C okay and
you have you have many of them right you
have one here and so on and each one has
a different C and each of these networks
represents one blue dot here so if you
let C vary so this sigmoid slope value
right here
that's your parameter C if you let this
variant rain the big Network on the
entire dataset to convergence and then
you eval on the validation data set you
get the slope like the blue curve so if
you see the blue curve the blue curve is
if you start over here if you reduce the
slope you'll gain in performance but if
you reduce it too much you drop
drastically okay until it's if it's if
it's zero it's basically you know the
the X is not if the signal doesn't
propagate any more and you you have no
learning occurring okay so that's the
original performance
now what if I only give you training
data in this range right here I only
showed you this particular range I can
can't actually zoom in that much but if
if I give you this and I ask you to
build one of these please take the
architecture and predict the performance
that we saw at the beginning like one of
these girdle machines or Turing Turing
machines you would
it's basically say well that looks to me
like a line so I'm gonna predict the red
thing here and even if you can you know
evaluate a bunch
these it just looks like a line and
you're going to predict it's probably a
slope like this right this happens
almost independently of which model you
choose to predict right here the the
data of training is simply doesn't give
away that the fact that there is a there
is this break down here which happens in
the real world so if you just give this
as training data there is no way so um
so the the criticism about these models
is valid that they will only work where
you give them training date so they can
at best interpolate their training data
but they can't really extrapolate now
here since the synthetic petri-dish
method which is the green thing here it
uses the actual not the actual
non-linearity that this thing
characterizes so it it instantiates the
sigmoid with the parameter C that you
give it just not on the large network
but on a small network in fact their
network is just one unit sorry one unit
and then another unit so it's just a two
hidden layer but just with one unit
instead of 100 and of course you can't
feed in M nest right here right but we
said they don't feed in the data they
actually feed in their synthetic data
that they learn so you give them the
points here and they learn the synthetic
data to to evaluate to evaluate the
others and then once you ask them well
if if my C is right here what's the
performance going to be it's going to
instantiate that in its small Network it
is going to use the training data that
it has learned from this region right
here in order to train this and then
it's going to evaluate this on the
synthetic validation data that is also
learned on the training data and it is
going to come up with a performance
metric it says okay this is how good
it's going to be and since it is an
approximation in its building plan to
the entire network it will react
similarly so it will get that there
this performance tip right here okay so
it you can see how this sort of makes
sense you're actually running an
approximation to the actual program
instead of just looking at the plan of
the program and trying to predict it
which you know halting problem says
hello okay so that is the motivating
example of there M NIST thing and here
is the entire algorithm all right so you
take M nest training and validation data
and you instantiate a bunch of really
big networks this is ground truth okay
you need this you need this to learn
from you instantiate a bunch of really
big networks now if I draw the graph
from before right we had this was the
performance of the actual networks you
want you this comes from here from this
region right here this is the training
data okay so you instantiate a bunch of
these networks each one you instantiate
in one of them right each one gives rise
to a different non-linearity and you do
the full training ground truth training
and evaluation on the full training set
and the full validation set and you get
validation losses right for each of
these and these are the points right
here now you that's the training data
for your neural for your neural
architecture search so for your petri
dish method what the petri dish does is
it says it extracts the motive and the
motive is the thing that you optimize
over so as I said you want to keep that
thing in its essence but you want to
reduce everything else so it reduces it
instead of from a two-layer 100y ml ml p
it reduces that to a two layer single
neuron wide MLP okay and it now this
over here is the training data for the
procedure that we're going to do now so
what it would take is it would take it
would take one of these values it would
instantiate we have
here would instantiate the neural
network in the small form of that and
now we know that if I train the full
data and evaluate if I train on the full
training data and evaluate on the full
validation data I should get this
accuracy all right so I will create and
we're going to look at in a second I
will create training and validation data
such that if I train on this training
data and then validate on this
validation data I get the same
validation loss as if I had trained the
big network with the same you know the
same C parameter on the full training
data and evaluate on the full validation
data okay so in this step I'm optimizing
the data here the training and
validation data alright and now in the
second step once I have this training
and validation data such that I can
basically reproduce this this graph
right here then I can go and actually
ask my model ok now please tell me what
happens over here so what am I gonna do
I'm gonna take that I'm gonna
instantiate it I'm going to use my
training data that I learned to train it
I'm going to use my validation data that
I learned to evaluate it and it's going
to give me a number and that number is
going to be like close to hopefully
close to do this so this is how we can
extrapolate using that method okay now
there are a number of assumptions right
here and you can imagine this doesn't
work in any situation this works if if
you you know if you basically you have
to get lucky in that you have to
abstract the correct things right I said
you need to reduce everything else so
they reduce notably you see they reduce
the 100 the 100 layer width to a single
neuron wide MLP and they sort of guessed
that that doesn't change the fundamental
thing but you can also see they leave
the two layer right they'll
leave the to the two-layer neural
network and I can almost guarantee you
that they tried this reducing this to a
one layer neural network and it did not
work and so you have to be sort of very
careful of what quantities you abstract
and what quantities you don't because
okay now you might always think oh I can
reduce the you know number of dimensions
or channels that's also not always the
case so I think that's kind of the crux
of the method you have to actually
engineer this down compressing of the
architecture such that it's its
properties are still kept and yeah but
yeah in other things how do you how do
you actually produce training and
validation data to match these and there
are a number of ways but what comes to
mind is is meta-learning
right so because what you're doing they
initialize the training and validation
data at random points so these are just
random at the beginning and then they
optimize the data itself using gradient
descent okay now I see synthetic
training data and they are randomly
initialized okay and they use gradient
descent they have it somewhere yes so
they have this inner training loop okay
which is many steps of inner training
and then they have the outer loss which
is the it's the validation loss after
the inner training loop and the
difference for that to the true
validation loss and then they do
gradient descent on this outer loss
now this outer loss is a result of the
inner loss and the inner loss is a
result of the inner training procedure
and the inner training procedure is n
steps of feeding in the training data
every step you feed in the training data
so your computational graph is going to
look like so here is your training data
S train and here are your initial
parameters you randomly initialize them
randomly in the first step use the
training data to produce theta one then
in the second step you use your
raining per amp new training data again
to produce theta - and then you use it
again to use theta free and so on each
time you feed the training data in order
to evolve your parameters to give you a
better prediction right so the gradient
is in somewhere back here there's a loss
the gradient here will have to flow back
through all of these paths and through
all of these connections to the training
data this is kind of you back propagate
through an optimization procedure and we
have this a bunch of times here and I've
looked at the code and the code is like
really crazy and it looks like proper
research code but it appears to be that
that's actually what's happening they
back prop through the optimization
procedure to find this synthetic
training and validation data now that's
I mean that's crazy but it also kind of
limits how far you can go with this
because usually you can't back prop for
more than a couple of steps doing this
now that the model of fact that the
model inner model is small helps but
also this introduces very very much like
these things are very brittle if you
back prop through an optimization
procedure like this these things tend to
be very brittle and so I think in
there's another thing there where you
have to pay careful attention all right
that's it's basically it the last thing
they say is that they can combine this
with architect research in that so not
only can you predict good architectures
what you can do is you can actually
predict the witch architectures are good
and then you can use that prediction to
get new to basically input this into
your neural architecture search to
inform it so instead of the neural
architecture search having to evaluate
all of the candidates that it produces
it only has to now evaluate the very
small subset of candidates that these
synthetic petri-dish training deems most
worthy of being evaluated in this case
here instead of evaluating all of the
things here it would limit itself to
whatever the synthetic petri dish says
are the highest-performing ones because
if the synthetic pay tradition is any
good then it will you know give accurate
predictions of how they're performing
and then that can go in in multiple
rounds so the architecture search can
find new come up with new things that it
thinks are better through like an
evolutionary mutation algorithm the
petri dish can evaluate them in the
synthetic way and then suggest the like
ten candidates to evaluate on the full
test set and use that way you don't have
to evaluate all the like thousand
candidates all right all right cool they
do this for this emne stand they also do
it for finding a RNN cell for the penn
treebank this is a language modeling
task and the new this is a benchmark for
a neural architecture search where
you're trying to find a a good or NN
cell to get the perplexity really low
and here you can see if they give the
same amount of data to all the methods
then the benchmark neural architecture
search is worse than the synthetic petri
dish informed architecture search now
one has to say on the full data I
believe the nao gets to about here but
of course if you give all of them the
same data the neural the petri dish
beats this method and I think still this
method here uses way more compute
because it always has to evaluate all
the candidates and that's exactly one of
these where I learn an architecture to
predict the other architecture by just
looking at it so it works but it doesn't
work as well as actually running the
architecture in an abstract fashion this
also shows you the importance of
selecting your experimental evaluation
in a smart way
like they argue they argue for very long
why it makes sense to evaluate
everything on reduced data such that
their method here can
be better and they don't have to compare
to the full thing it's easier for them
to work on reduced data and they argue
you know that's it's it's what people
usually do in practice and that's the
task they focus on so you know good good
good good paper writing right here yeah
that's basically it to the paper there's
a lot of things to be said here I think
this works in very very limited settings
it seems to me that it's sort of brittle
with respect to how you abstract and
also it it's always the case like how
many how large is the synthetic training
data in their case they they like
abstract this to twenty or thirty data
points or something like this
so it seems to me since you're
optimizing this training data with
gradient descent what you would mainly
find our adversarial sort of adversarial
examples to this architecture here so
I'm going to guess that the inner
optimization is very noisy and that's
because if you really let your optimizer
run then it will abuse every single
thing it can to match that validation
loss and that will usually lead to an
adversarial example since you're
optimizing the data itself okay so I
think this suffers from that and this is
we had this in the in the planning you
know the planning in in learned world
models and reinforcement learning where
if you have a really really good planner
it will just abuse the mistakes that you
make in approximating the true world and
the same here you're going to make
mistakes approximating this architecture
here and the better your your optimizer
is for producing this synthetic data the
probably the worse the worse the result
is going to match the worse that these
losses are going to actually match now
ok these losses will match because
they're that's what you trained for but
the worse these two curves will match
each other because now you're just
finding adversarial example
for your particular training data
another concern I have here is with
respect to the double descent phenomenon
so if you know the double descent
phenomenon if here you have your number
of parameters and here you have your
validation loss let's say and you know
that if I add parameters I can make my
validation loss go down so this is
assuming I have a model with P per a
meters and I always train it on the
train data to like to convergence if I
add parameters I can generalize better
until a point where I add too many
parameters and I start overfitting and
my validation loss goes up again but the
double descent phenomenon and I think
I've done a video on this shows that
after a certain threshold you get the
interpolation threshold the validation
else goes actually down again and goes
down even further here now I'm so this
is a very strange phenomenon by itself
but I'm sort of concerned that if you do
this abstraction that this paper
proposes so you read your let's say your
full model is here with a large number
of parameters so it has passed this
interpolation threshold if you now
seriously reduce the number of
parameters because you want to go into
this petri dish you will get maybe you
will cross this interpolation threshold
and actually be on this side of the
curve right here now of course at the
same time you reduce the amount of data
which would push you over here again but
it is different data so I'm not sure how
all of this is going to play out it
appears to work in these settings right
here but I I think this is it's it's
sort of it's sort of applicable in some
situations and it's it'd be very cool if
we develop this further such that we
understand when it applies and when we
can use it because I feel this can be a
very cool thing if we understand it
better and if we can apply it throughout
all right that's the end if you like
this paper leave a comment if you didn't
like it leave a comment
and bye-bye see you next time